Tony Juniper.
He's an environmentalist and former executive director of friends of the earth.
He's the author of what has nature ever done for us?
How money really does grow on trees.
What nature does for Britain and rainforest dispatches from Earth's most vital
frontlines. He's also the co-author with the Prince of Wales of harmony,
a new way of looking at our world.
Okay.
Thank you, Richard. Good evening, ladies and gentlemen,
I have to say that in my long career, as an environmentalist,
I reached the conclusion that the question we're debating this evening is the
most important of all. Namely,
what kind of economic system is going to enable us to navigate the climate
change and nature emergency.
And while many people talk about population growth,
and the fact that our numbers have tripled since 1950,
bear in mind that the size of the global economy has increased 10 fold.
And the consequences of that we can see in elevated greenhouse gas emissions,
the mass extinction of animals and plants and ecological degradation on a
global scale.
If you look at the way different economies have greeted these trends over the
decades,
it's largely been seen as the price of progress with both
socialist and capitalist systems,
both seeking to expand output as the means of achieving human
wellbeing,
both systems capitalist and socialist saw growth as their most vital
and essential objective. One promoted the process by a markets,
private property and corporations, the other via central planning,
state ownership of industry and workers,
managing the organizations that employed them,
both saw the rapid exploitation of natural resources as
central to their plans to expand GDP.
They both wanted to expand the size of the pie with capitalists,
expecting the wealth to trickle down through society and socialists,
engaging in more or less active redistribution.
Looking at the last hundred years of economic experiments conducted under those
two banners.
It's fair to say that we have not yet invented a large scale economic
system that can be regarded as ecologically sustainable.
And as previous speakers have pointed out this evening,
this is now a matter of grave urgency.
We have to shift from where we are to a sustainable economy in a matter of
years. And as we consider the importance of urgency,
just bear in mind that pretty much all democracies across the world vote
for some kind of capitalist system,
whether it's the socially progressive form that you see in some of the
Scandinavian countries or the neoliberal accesses of the United States.
Broadly speaking, that is what citizens back.
If we are going to make this shift in time,
then we're going to need to find ways of getting citizens to back that economic
transformation in ways that they would like,
and looking at the world from where I see it at the moment is going to be most
likely to do that through some form of capitalist transformation,
changing the system that we have, rather than pushing it off a cliff.
And if we are to succeed,
then we need to harness the dynamic innovation of markets of competition and the
inventiveness that comes with the profit motive. If we're going to do that,
what kind of system might we envisage? So unlike the other side, this evening,
ladies and gentlemen,
I'm going to give you some solutions rather than simply a diagnosis of the
problem. And it's not going to be a five year Soviet plan.
It's going to be a five-point capitalist transformation program.
Point one in this transformation program is to adopt legal frameworks,
adopted by governments to embed hard caps, to reflect the need,
to reduce to zero greenhouse gas emissions and to restore the natural
environment that needs to be done globally through the convention on
biodiversity and the convention on climate change and domestically through
things like the climate change act and the environment act that was introduced
into parliament today,
we need targets set out in law that reflect the scale of the
ecological emergency. Once we've established the caps,
we need to put in place the tools and the policies to meet those new goals.
We can do this through the regulation on emission standards,
through the regulation of the financial markets, supportive trade policy.
And of course, in relation to climate change of price on carbon,
imagine what would happen if over the next 10 years we introduced a 100 pounds,
carbon tax per ton,
10 pounds a year rising between 2020 and 2030,
that would send a very clear signal that it's time to get out of fossil fuels.
It would be transformative,
and it could be part of a wider ecological tax reform program whereby
people on lower incomes at the income tax reduced.
And instead we levy taxation on pollution.
Three. Yeah.
And this plan would be a shift of the subsidies regime been pointed out already.
Quite rightly,
that hundreds of billions of pounds are awarded to fossil fuel corporations and
industrial agriculture across the globe. Every year,
we need to switch those subsidies into the cleaner and greener alternatives,
sustainable regenerative, agriculture, renewable energy amongst them.
These three steps, hard limits,
new regulatory tools and reoriented subsidies would ensure that the ultimate
means of economic activity,
namely a healthy biosphere would be better protected on top of this.
However,
it would also be necessary to correct the rather fundamental fact that Neo rib
neoliberal capitalism has lost sight of why it exists the first place.
This is why parts four and five of the transformation plan are about ensuring
that capitalism delivers longterm wellbeing for all,
rather than hoping that self-interested buyers and sellers will deliver that
automatically. We know that they won't do so.
Part four would be the adoption of new measures to judge economic
success,
embracing human wellbeing and ecological sustainability as central
measures of performance of the economy,
not simple crude GDP that would be put into the dustbin of
history where it belongs instead of measuring and celebrating increased,
consumption, and waste, which is basically what GDP growth does.
We would have economic measures to instead celebrate long,
happy and sustainable lives. For everybody.
Part five would focus on the private sector companies that at the very beating
heart of the capitalist system,
they would be subject to new laws requiring that they be driven by a purpose to
promote the wellbeing of people in society.
Not simply the interests of shareholders, companies would still harness markets,
profits, and innovation,
but they would do it against a new set of goals that were set out in new
company laws. They would still seek profits, but not,
not necessarily profit maximization,
nor profit via any legal route.
Their purpose would be sustainable development.
Governments can legislate for all of these things and in different parts of the
world in different ways. They're beginning to do it.
We need to put supercharges on that agenda. However,
my argument is evening is not predicated on the view that it's capitalism per
se, that has caused the mess we were in,
but rather the economic system more broadly,
whether it be capitalist socialist or anything else that we've invented,
we are very, very short of time.
People want positive alternatives that they can vote for looking around the
world where people presently past cast their votes.
I would say the best chance we've got is to change capitalism,
to invest in its transformation,
not to push it off a cliff because that will end an even more certain disaster.
Thank you very much.
[Inaudible] well, thank you very much.